turn now panel on poetry for children
with the weekly standards Joseph bottom
and William Kristol National Endowment
for the Arts chairman Dana Joya Vanity
Fair columnist Christopher Hitchens and
author Mary ever stat it's an hour 20
minutes
welcome how are y'all great great to see
here my name is Michael Novak the George
critic chair here at AEI I don't know
the 8th or 9th or 10th I want a little
cultural series these are not official
events of AEI but the president does
allow us to here's the rooms and put
them on and we finance it ourselves
there were our sponsors needn't worry
that we're not using their great
contributions for non public policy
matters but we are using the format is
more important than public policy and
I'm really thrilled and honored that
Jodi bottom agreed to put together this
stellar panel for a reading of
children's poetry so that we could
invite the next generation of the next
generation to be here with us and enjoy
this evening I'll turn it over to Jodi
for the introductions and I think we're
going to have a really really good time
Jodi please Thanks this program came
about because writers will do anything
absolutely anything to avoid keeping a
promise last summer I took in advance to
write a new book on thanks I took an
advance to write a new book on the state
of Catholicism in America so naturally I
had to find something else to do and
some way of avoiding actually doing that
and the best thing I could come up with
was to spend the next three or four
months writing some children's poems and
when I mentioned to our friend Michael
Novak that my new manuscript was
children's poetry he suggested that I
put together a panel of people here in
Washington to read their favorites and
to Nadder a little bit about what
children's poetry is and what it's for
and what we should be looking for in it
now you have to understand the nation's
capitol is famous for many things but
comic children's poetry really isn't one
of them in fact poetry at all isn't the
first thing that comes to mind when you
think of Washington DC although the
comic children part might anyway there
were no obvious choices here in town so
I asked the next six people to whom I
happen to owe an email to join me today
and read and
talk a little bit about children's verse
and because God really does look out for
idiots like me we ended up with this
unbelievable panel of people my name is
Joseph bottom and I'm the literary
editor the Weekly Standard and poetry
editor of a magazine up in New York
called first things our friend
Christopher Buckley it was supposed to
be here today was unfortunately called
away but we still have Dana Joya who's
the chairman of the National Endowment
for the Arts and a celebrated poet and
critic whose latest volume is
disappearing ink
Ryan poetry at the end of the print
culture our second we have Christopher
Hitchens a widely published essayist
columnist for Vanity Fair and the
Atlantic Monthly and everywhere else and
author most recently of love poverty and
more journeys and essays next we have
Tim Kelleher who's an actor writer and
director in Los Angeles in New York
whose film credits include the role of
Ted Sorenson in Roger Donaldson's movie
thirteen days and perhaps more to the
point the voice of Raphael in the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles we have
William Kristol my boss the editor of
The Weekly Standard and a well-known
political commentator for national
television writer everywhere and finally
met Mary a burstad who's a consulting
editor to the magazine policy review and
author of the phenomenal new book home
alone America the hidden toll of daycare
behavioral drugs and other parents
substitutes now I'm gonna start us off
with a poem for my new manuscript
because well mostly because I set up
this panel in it's mine all mine no but
I also because one of the things that we
can talk about a little when we natter
here today is how much of children's
poetry is not for children at all or
maybe what I mean is that a lot of
children's poems run on two levels at
the same time there's the bounce the
tongue to tongue to determine the speed
and the nonsense the children love and
at the same time there's a joke in them
for adults now maybe this has to do
through this has to be so because you
need to get parents actually to read
those poems to the children you should
always remember the fact that publishers
have never forgotten
a fact which publishers have never
forgotten which is it's the parents who
buy the books not the children but
there's also a deeper reason maybe for
why so much children's poetry wants to
have a second level that appeals to
adults
anyway this poem of mine is called
reading by osmosis and it's from my many
friends both young and old who know the
names of many many more authors and
books than they've ever actually read
it's called reading by osmosis and it
goes Wow Mark Twain Harte crane and
Ursula K Le Guin we've mastered their
books with a difficult trick we've read
them outside in Percy Bysshe Shelley and
Machiavelli and norman vincent peale
we've never tried opening one of their
books we know them by their feel does
reading seem boring does reading seem
hard does reading seem too ferocious
then pick up a book and just give it a
twirl you'll learn it by Osmos because
osmosis is the mostest osmosis is the
best osmosis is the closest thing to
reading without rest osmosis means
absorbing osmosis means so much osmosis
means were soaking up the books we
barely touch Harriet Beecher Stowe and
Henry David Thoreau and Daniel Defoe and
Jacques Rousseau and Oh hundreds of
others we know we bobble bounce and
throw them we never even look osmosis
means we know them without opening a
book you know my sister oz moated the
mill on the floss a marvelous book and
gave us a gloss concerning a man named
John Stuart Mill with terrible teeth
that made him quite ill why oh why
wouldn't he floss
my brother Osmo did the Lord of the
Rings a story of insects with thousands
of wings or was that a book called Lord
of the Flies oh well we're getting wise
by learning the things that osmosis now
brings will juggle the books little
women and men they're all about dwarves
in a mountain eden and throw in a copy
of watership down concerning a boat and
some sailors who drown and then
we'll run to the bookstore again but
first let's have a word from dr. dare
Xena who comes here today all the way
from Vienna to teach us the meaning of
difficult things there now V begin
osmosis this is meaning that Ventris
things are leaning Zevon into the other
tries to sneak the liquid on see right
through membranes overnight we'll to the
left most definitely leak while coming
here i sat on dictionaries fat learn
disease by riding on z book but if you
have neurosis mine genius is hypnosis
you will mine eyes most deeply into uhm
neurosis hypnosis psychosis meiosis
lovely words in their way
cirrhosis necrosis and also thrombosis
pleasing but harder to say and atrocious
prognosis of miss diagnosis for aches of
precocious sclerosis but words will find
their apathy Oh sis remains the great oz
boasts as we boast we boast osmosis is
the most phenomenal way to read a while
eating jam and toast we shout we plead
osmosis we will need for plane Jackson
munching snacks and dancing while we
read so rebecca west and edgar guest
will never be certain which one is the
best
christopher smart and sean pulse are
just think of the wonders they have to
impart poets of genius like Julia Moore
and William McGonagall call for a roar
William Shakespeare Edward de Vere the
difference isn't entirely clear
Somerset mom and L frank baum's Josiah
Royce and James Joyce John Bunyan and
Damon Runyon
Graham Greene and Mollie King Tom Paine
and ed McBaine Ring Lardner and John
Gardner CP snow and Arthur Rimbaud and
hundreds of others we know because
osmosis is the mostest osmosis is the
best osmosis is the closest thing to
reading without rest osmosis means
absorbing osmosis means so much knows
Moses means we're soaking up the books
we barely touch we hold them to our
noses we brush them with our clothes
we're learning by osmosis when we tap
them with our toes we pile them on the
table we slide them on the floor we
stack them in two stairways and we climb
up for some more
we bobble bounce and throw them we never
even look osmosis means we know them
without opening since Jodie are recited
a poem that danced I'll do one that
tells a story it seems to me that people
that really love poetry almost always
learned to love poetry as children and
there's something about the experience
of actually hearing a poem before you
can read a poem on a page which i think
is much closer to what the experience of
poetry really is which is about speech
raised to a level that it's memorable
and expressive this is a poem that
probably most of you don't know it's by
a very famous poet AE Housman
and he wrote poems in the letters that
he sent to his nephew and his niece that
were never included in his collected
poems but they're rather good this one
also has something I think that's very
important for children's poetry which is
disruptive and slightly subversive
energy
it's called inhuman Henry or cruelty to
fabulous animals Oh would you know why
Henry sleeps and why is morning mother
weeps and why his weeping mother mourns
he was unkind to unicorns no unicorn
with Henry's leave could dance upon the
vaunted Eve org or the gardener's boy in
spring or do the very slightest thing no
unicorn could safely roar or - its nose
against the door nor sit in peace upon
the mat to eat the dog or drink the cat
Henry would never in the least
encourage the heraldic beast if there
were unicorns about he went and let the
lion out the lion leaping from its chain
and glaring through its tangled Mane
would stand on end and bark and bound
and bite what unicorns it found and when
the lion bit a lot was Henry sorry he
was not what did his jumps have joy the
token joy he was a very bloody minded
boy the unicorn is not a goose and when
it sees a lion loose
they grew increasingly aware that they
had better not be there and oh the
unicorn is fleet and spurns the earth
with all its feet the lion had the snap
and snatch at tips of tails it could not
catch returning home in temper bad it
met the sanguinary lad and clasping
henry with its jaws his cause it took
his legs between his jaws down lion down
said henry cease my legs immediately
release his formidable feline pet nato
no reply but only at the last words that
were ever said by Henry's disappearing
head in accents of indignant scorn were
I am NOT a unicorn
and now you know why Henry sleeps and
why his mother mourns and weeps and why
she also weeps and mourns so now be kind
to unicorns you see before you
in the in purple nose that looks as if a
door has been slammed on it was if it's
stopped a fist in a fight the nerves of
a father who went sledding
neither wisely nor too well in a frozen
Washington this weekend when I was small
I was made to listen to a lot of him
tunes I think my childhood I wise was
rather prosaic but when I began to feel
that I had some ear for poetry was it
was in the ear it was the feeling that
if it was poetry it would be memorized
or could be memorized and that this was
the oral tradition extending backwards
to Homer and I became what was dogmatic
about it if you can't memorize it poorly
isn't a very good poem at a school which
my father later helped to run there was
a poetry competition every year for the
boys and it was called a poetry saying
competition jetha was very well put the
poetry saying would be held and real boy
the school Cecil day-lewis used to come
and judge the poetry saying and he
became the first person I ever asked
Charlie to sign a book for me and I have
it still but that might be too grave an
introduction to what I proposed to
recite which is a piece of nonsense from
Lewis Carroll the Reverend Dodgson this
is in the same city of Oxford as I have
this signature from Davis Jody and I
once he's reminded me discussed why it
was that just about the time the French
invented surrealism the English came up
with nonsense
this may have been the opening of a
longer battle than we know at any rate
some of you will recognize at least some
of it when I say it was brillig and the
slithy Toves did gyre and gimble in the
way all mimsy were the borogroves and
the mome Raths outgrabe
beware the Jabberwock my son the jaws
that bite the teeth the cache beware the
Jubjub bird and shun the frumious
Bandersnatch
he took his vorpal sword in hand long
time the Manx and fairy sword then
rested he by the Tumtum tree and stood
awhile in thought and as in uffish
thought he stood the jabberwock with
eyes of flame came whiffling through the
tulgey wood and burbled as it came
one two one two and through and through
the vorpal blade went snicker-snack
he left it dead and with its head he
went galumphing bag and hast thou slain
the Jabberwock come to my arms my
Beamish boy a fragile day
Callooh Callay he chortled in his joy
which was brillig and the slithy Toves
did gyre and gimble in the wave all
mimsy were the borogroves and the mome
Raths
hello before we go a step further I have
to look into the camera until my niece
Jennifer the Unicorn is okay don't worry
about a thing she has a great collection
and affection for unicorns I guess we're
all here because poetry has come to mean
a great deal to all of us in some
fashion but contrary to mr. joy I I
didn't like poetry very much when I was
growing up and it wasn't until I was at
least well into college that I actually
started enjoying home poetry because I
started writing poems not knowing a
thing about how it was done and I guess
I caught Jody napping one day because he
agreed to publish one of them so I'm
gonna read the first problem in a read
is from Jody's collection and I think
it's obvious why
Robert and Martha and sweet little Jo
sweet sweet Jo for the pleasantest
children that you'll ever know Robert
and Martha and Jo they picked up their
toys they eat all their Peas they never
made noise they always said please each
was a precious and wonderful jewel while
sometimes they even left early for
school but once they got outside they
kicked the neighbours cat
they stole a baby's hat and they tripped
old mr. Johnson so he fell down with a
splat then Martha punched a boy so Joker
grabbed his toy while young Robert
looked for something he could easily
destroy two students they were rude in
their classes they were booed and they
broke into the lunchroom
to add pepper to the food they sang
off-key in choir and they slashed their
teachers tire and while walking home
that afternoon they said a church on
fire
Oh Robert and Martha and sweet little Jo
sweet sweet Jo
they were the awfulest children that
you'll ever know Robert and Martha and
Jo so red sky up morning parents take
warning red sky at night parents take
fright keep children happy clean and I
shout never ever let them go out
those games or puzzles where there are
those lists and you're supposed to pick
out this is I think I des is also on
tests SATs
who or what doesn't fit in this list I
feel that I'm this is my my role up here
is to make everyone else look good which
I'm happy to do Jodie asked me to come
here with published poets memorizers of
poetry and appreciators sophisticated
appreciators of poetry and then there's
me
I actually I know poetry shouldn't child
children's poetry is supposed to be read
to children to amuse them or entertain
them or educate them I mostly I didn't
mean very much poetry to our kids and
what I did it was mostly to get them to
go to sleep therefore I read to them up
to the age of five and that is so I
thought I would begin I want to say one
more thing about the kids I mean it is
actually a pleasure to be here and such
distinguished people but I must say I
didn't realize I'd be sitting next to
Tim who in addition to his other
achievements but most importantly of
course is the voice of one of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles which is I
mean I've sat next to many people at AI
panels but this is by far the what I'm
most impressed bhai
and my kids would be too I'm sure
anyway I thought it would be just to
begin with two very short two picture
books which flow you know most of you
which I actually did read to our kids
which I they mate they they retain
snatches of and I even not retained
snatches of the first is by Sandra
Boynton most famous for her excellent
but not the hippopotamus but I won't we
do that I'll meet you they're going to
bed book consistent my theme here of
putting people to sleep let's see if all
the little kids not off here than two
minutes it's a picture book so I can't
really make up for the you know the
excellent illustrations but this is
called the going to bed book the Sun has
set
not long ago now everybody goes below to
take a bath and one big tub its soap all
over scrub scrub scrub they hang their
towels on the wall and find pajamas they
can swallow with some on top and
somebody they brush and brush and brush
their teeth and when the moon is on the
rise they all go up to exercise
and down once more but not so fast
they're on their way to bed at last the
day is done they say good night and
somebody turns off the light the moon is
high the sea is deep they rock and rock
and rock to sleep going to explain that
these are animals on a ship and the
second is also short very famous good
night moon by Margaret wise Brown in the
Great Green Room there was a telephone
and a red balloon and the picture of the
cow jumping over the moon and there were
three little bears sitting on chairs and
two little kittens and a pair of mittens
and a little toy house and a young Mouse
and a comb brush and a bowl full of mush
and a quiet old lady who was whispering
hush
good night room good night moon good
night cow jumping over the moon
good night light and the red balloon
good night Bears good night shares
good night kittens and good night
mittens
good night clocks and good night socks
good night little house and good night
Mouse
good night home and good night brush
goodnight nobody goodnight mush and good
night to the old lady whispering hush
good night stars
good night air good night noises
everywhere
well I feel a little like Bill here on
as best I can tell I'm here for one of
two reasons neither particularly
elevated one because Jody's my friend
and he's allowing me to shamelessly I
exploit the occasion to mention my new
book home alone America the other even
more politically incorrect reason is
that it was my great good fortune to
marry well and in particular to marry
Nicholas Nash ever stat who is the
grandson of Ogden Nash and which is to
say Ogden Nash his poetry is fairly well
known in our household and I thought I
would start by reading one called the
adventures of Isabel Ogden Nash had two
daughters Linnell and Isabel Isabel is
Nick's mother and there is also an
Isabel sitting in the back who is our
Isabel and I would like to read this for
her Isabel met an enormous bear Isabel
Isabel didn't care
the bear was hungry the bear was
ravenous the Bears big mouth was cruel
and cavernous the bear said Isabel glad
to meet you how do is Val now I'll eat
you Isabel Isabel didn't worry
Isabel didn't scream or scurry she
washed her hands and she straightened
her hair up and Isabel quietly ate the
Vera
once in a night as black as pitch Isabel
met a wicked old witch the witch's face
was cross and wrinkled the witch's gums
with teeth were sprinkled ho ho Isabel
the old witch crowed I'll turn you into
an ugly toad Isabel Isabel didn't worry
Isabel didn't scream or scurry she
showed no rage and she showed no rancor
but she turned the witch into milk and
drank her Isabel met a hideous giant
Isabel continued self-reliant the giant
was hairy the giant was horrid he had
one eye in the middle of his forehead ah
good morning is about the giant said
I'll grind your bones to make my bread
Isabel Isabel didn't worry
Isabel didn't scream or scurry she
nibbled his way back that she always fed
off and when it was gone she caught the
Giants head off
Isabel met a troublesome doctor he
punched and he poked till he really
shocked her the doctors talk was of
coughs and chills and the doctors
satchel bulged with pills the doctor
said unto Isabel swallow this it'll make
you well Isabel Isabel didn't worry
Isabel didn't scream or scurry she took
those pills from the pill concoct her
and Isabel calmly cured the doctor
almost all the great children's poetry
seems to have been written around 1911
and how we write more is the question
the Edwardian seemed to find a vein of
children's poetry that's been very hard
to get out of now there there are more
modern posts that I like a great deal XJ
Kennedy and David McCord who was a
favorite of Robert Frost's and Jack
Prelutsky is is another one I like shel
silverstein I know has a big audience
I've never been a big fan of his but
some of our other readers today are
going to convince me that I'm wrong when
they read some of it but I want to go
back to one of those earlier poems one
of those Edwardian poems and ask
ourselves sort of why is it that they
could do stuff that we can't this is a
poem by a man otherwise unknown named
AML maybe maybe you have heard of him
and he wrote a number of poems he just
struck out on a vein and wrote a number
of poems which also had a joke in them
for adults although even at that time it
would be difficult for many adults to
get the trick of this one which the joke
of it for adults being that the lines
are in perfect the perfect hexameter of
Ovid as I say you have to there's a
level of adult joke that even the
edwardian didn't get and we probably
don't either and yet somehow those Latin
long and short rhythms translated into
English accents come out in only one of
two ways like comic verse or like
children's verse and this one is called
disobedience notice by the way Dana
talked about a kind of subversive energy
in this in children's poetry notice of
subversion here it's the mother who's
disobeying the child in this poem rather
than the other way around and it goes
quite famously it opens
James James Morris and Morris and
Weatherby George Dupree that by the way
is a perfect hexameter for those of you
with Latin for the rest of us it just
bounces right along took great care of
his mother though he was only three
James James said to his mother mother he
said Sidhe you must never go down to the
end of the town if you don't go down
with me James James Morrison's mother
put on a golden gown James James
Morrison's mother drove to the end of
the town James James Morrison's mother
said to herself said she I can get right
down to the end of the town and be back
in time for tea King John put up a
notice lost or stolen or strayed James
James Morrison's mother seems to have
been mislaid last seen wandering vaguely
quite of her own accord she tried to get
down to the end of the town 40 shillings
reward James James Morris and Morrison
commonly known as Jim told his other
relations not to go blaming him James
James said to his mother mother he said
said he you must never go down to the
end of the town without consulting me
James James Morrison's mother hasn't
been heard of since King John said he
was sorry so did the Queen and Prince
King John somebody told me said to a man
he knew if people go down to the end of
the town well what can anyone do now
very softly je je aime m WG dou P took
great care of his hmm
though he was only
j-jane said to us she said said he you
must never go down to the end of the
town if you don't go down with I want to
read a poem by Ogden ashes we Judaism I
want to read a poem by Ogden Nash - this
is uh a poem that my mother read to me
when I was a little boy I think she
found it in The Saturday Evening Post I
can't figure out any other way a
contemporary poem would have entered our
working-class household in Hawthorne
California and this poem among its many
virtues has one of my favorite rhymes I
won't give you the whole rhyme but it's
the rhyme that rhymes with household
it's called the tale of custard the
dragon which keeps my theme of fabulous
animals going Belinda lived in a little
White House with a little black kitten
and a little gray mouse and a little
yellow dog and a little red wagon and
really Oh truly Oh little pet dragon now
the name of the little black kitten was
ink and the little grey mouse she called
her blink and the little yellow dog was
sharp as mustard but the dragon was a
coward and she called him custard
custard the dragon had big sharp teeth
and spikes on top of him and scales
underneath mouth like a fireplace
chimney for a nose and really Oh truly
Oh daggers on his toes Belinda was brave
as a barrel full of bears and ink and
blink chased Lions down the stairs
mustard was brave as a tiger in rage but
custard cried for a nice safe cage
Belinda tickled him she tickled him
unmerciful ink blinkin mustard
they rudely called him Percival
they all set with a thing in the little
red wagon at the 'really oh truly Oh
cowardly dragon Belinda giggled till it
shook the house and blink said week
which is giggling for a mouse ink and
mustard rudely asked his age when
custard cried for a nice safe cage
suddenly suddenly they heard a nasty
sound and mustard growled and they all
looked around me ouch
cried ink who cried Belinda for there
was a pirate climbing in the window
pistol in his left hand pistol in his
right he held his teeth in his teeth a
Cutlass price his beard was black one
leg was wood it was clear that the
pirate meant no good Belinda paled and
she cried help help but mustard fled
with a terrified Yelp ink trickled down
to the bottom of the household and the
little mouse blink strategically mouse
hold but up jumped custard snorting like
an engine crashed his tail like irons in
a dungeon with a clatter and a crank and
a jangling squirm he went at the pirate
like a Robin had a worm the pirate gaped
at Belinda's dragon and gulped some grog
from his pocket flagon he fired two
bullets but they didn't hit and custard
gobbled him every bit Belinda embraced
him mustard licked him no one mourned
his pirate victim ink and blink and
pleaded gyrate around the dragon that
ate the pie rate
valinda still lives in her little white
house with her little black kitten and
her little gray mouse and her little
yellow dog in her little red wagon and
aurelio truly oh little pet dragon
belinda is brave as a barrel full of
bears and ink and blink chase Lions down
the stairs
mustard is brave as attired as a tiger
in a rage but custard keeps crying for a
nice safe cage I'd hoped to be the one
who would introduce the pitiless note
now that I've heard first of all reading
right now I know what it would be like
to hear Leo Strauss treating my pet goes
probably too late for me to trash a a
Milne in the unsentimental where I was
brought up on Milne one had to be the
house at Pooh Corner to be succeeded by
when we were very young and now we are
six of which I must say Jody selection
by far the best but I remember the sense
of liberation that came upon me when I
read a parody that ended hush-hush
nobody cares
Christopher Robin has fallen downstairs
and so it was when I was quite small
myself that I seized upon Hilaire Belloc
and his cautionary tales and on whoever
it was to read ruthless rhymes from
heartless homes I can do some of them
Belloc from memory but I'm not gonna try
to do the main one but for example the
he wrote about Lord Finchley Lord
officially tried to amend the electric
light himself it struck him dead and
serve him right is the business of the
wealthy man to give employment to the
artisan that's fellow kin a gem like
Foreman in the opening of one of his
books for children he says speaking to
them and illustrating admittedly with
the cartoon
a fat old jet bending down to your
little hands were made to take the
better things and leave the worst ones
they also may be used to shake the
massive paws of elder persons but I
can't I can't now had to put on my
glasses actually read from Lord Lundy on
this a cautionary in verse Lord Lundy of
the superscription says who was too
freely moved to tears and thereby ruined
his political career Lord Lundy from his
earliest years was far too freely moved
two chairs for instance of his mother
said Lundy it's time to go to bed he
bellowed like a little Turk or if his
father Lord John Kirk said hi in a
commanding tone hi Lundy leave the cat
alone Lord Lundy lettin Gerdes tale
would raise so terrible a whale has
moved his grandfather Duke to other
utter the severe rebuke when I sir was a
little boy an animal was not toy his
father's father's eldest sister who was
married to a parvenu confided to her
husband drat the miserable peevish brat
why don't they drown the little beasts
suggestions wish to say the least are
not what we expect to hear from
daughters of an English peer his grandma
his mother's mother who had some dignity
or other the Garter or no matter what I
can't remember all the lot said oh that
I were brisk and spry to give him that
for which to cry
an empty wish alas for she was blind in
nearly 93 this verse I can't do the
Gerald Butler thought but there I really
neither knew nor care for what the dear
old but the thought in my opinion Butler
sought to know their place and not to
play the old retainer night and day I'm
getting tired and so you will cut the
poem into two second counter
the capital old longji darkness happens
to so many men towards the age of 26
they shoved him into politics in which
profession he commanded the income that
is rank demanded internist secretary for
India the colonies and war but very soon
his friends began to doubt if he'll
quite the man thus if a member rose to
say as members do from day to day
arising out of that reply Lord London
would begin to cry the hint at harmless
little jabs would shake it with
convulsive sobs while that's for
revelations these would simply bring him
to his knees and leave him whimpering
like a child he drove his colleagues
raving wild they let him sink from post
to post from 1500 at the most to eight
and barely six then to be curator of Big
Bend and finally the came of threat to
asked him from the cabinet the Duke his
aged grandsire bore of the shame till he
could bear no more he rallied his
declining past some of the youth to
Bradley Charles and visually addressed
him thus sir you have disappointed us we
had intended you to be the next prime
minister but three the stocks were sold
the press was squared the middle class
was quite prepared that as it is my
patience fails go out and govern New
South Wales the age of grants I drowned
and died and heavens have Lundy cry
ok let's have a show of hands how many
people in this room under the age of 12
is still awake ok I'm gonna need your
help in reading this next poem by mr.
Jody bottom okay and when I do need it
I'll put a little wave of a hand so pay
attention and help me out okay I didn't
hear you what I think that's just poem
is called bugs I once took a ladybug
home to tea down by the root of a
juniper tree and the ladybug fell asleep
I once saw a tipsy bumbling bee
slurping the juice of a slow plum tree
and the bee buzz and the ladybug fell
asleep a stink bug crawl past my knee up
at the top of a sycamore tree and the
stink bug squinched squint squint and
the bee buzz zur zur and the ladybug
fell asleep a fine fettle cricket sang
happy and free under the bloom of an
apricot tree and the cricket croaked in
the stinkbug squinched squint squint and
the be buzzed desert zerp and the
ladybug fell asleep not yet always a
grasshopper hopped in the grass near me
slow as a hound by a dogwood tree and
the grasshopper moaned mm-hmm and the
cricket croquet wicket and the stinkbug
squinched squint squint and the be
buzzed and the ladybug fell asleep I
once knew a fly who decided to flee deep
in the shade of an old oak tree and the
fly breezed
and the grasshopper moaned mm-hmm and
the cricket croaked cricket cricket and
the stinkbug squid squid squid and the
bee buzz sir and the ladybug fell asleep
I had no food for a hungry flee leaving
his friends in a lone pine tree and the
flee flew away in a huff and the flea
breezed burs and the grasshopper moaned
mm-hmm and the cricket croaked cricket
cricket the stick bug squinched
and the bee buzz and the ladybug fell
asleep a centipede marched up to three
crunching the shells from a chestnut
tree and the centipede drum
did he tongue to D tongue and the flea
flew away in a huff and the fly breathed
precision the grasshopper moan hmm hmm
and the cookie croaked cricket the
stinkbug squinched switch and the be
buzzed asleep a dragonfly promised he'd
fly to see high in the fronds of a tall
palm tree and the dragonfly world and
the centipede drum to determine to
determine the flea flew away in a huff
and the flea breathed preserves and the
grasshopper moaned and the cricket
croaked swish and the be buzzed to a
deep deep down in a heap no peep sleep
picked up my sleep theme there the that
thing about a mill and Ovid we all knew
that Sandra Boynton was more influenced
by Horus action I could give a little
disquisition on that well even though I
was a neglectful neglectful poetic
parent my wife Susan actually did read
the kids occasionally some decent poetry
and that was inspired I think by her
mother who read Susan and her sisters
and brother poetry and Louise Goldman
Sheinberg Susan's mother's favorite poem
was Robert for Marvin Lewis Stevenson's
a child's gardener verse and it's called
where go the boats dark-browed is the
river golden is the sand that flows
along forever with trees on either hand
green leaves of floating castles of the
foam boats of mine a boating where we'll
all come home on goes the river and out
past the middle way down the valley way
down the hill way down the river a
hundred miles or more other little
children sheltering by boats ashore
uh I have here another Ogden national
poem which is really being read for the
men on the panel who have children may
ever have been tempted to write about
them because this is the definitive word
about that it's called my daddy I have a
funny daddy who goes in and out with me
and everything that baby does my daddy's
store to see and everything that baby
says my daddy's sure to tell you must
have read my daddy's verse I hope he
fries and how
because when you're riding anything will
do for a topic and they're always around
these are actually I try a couple more
here these are a couple of my poems that
my new collection that my new manuscript
that used those same latin rythms that i
was talking about with mills to try and
create children's first it's a cruel
thing to do I know but I thought I'd
give it a try this first one is called
my family and me and it goes my dad is a
werewolf dogs bark and snarl at him in
Hyde Park his beard sprouts his eyes
spark a full moon drives him mad but mom
is a goblin no toys escaped the
pitchfork she employs her pointy ears
hate all noise I must be very calm my
sister's a zombie she seems to cause a
lot of loud screams our neighbors all
have bad dreams and wish that they had
missed her my brother now well who knows
just what he is but hair grows between
his toes and past his nose his eyeballs
watch each other and me I'll never be
mistook for one of them cuz I snuck a
peek in the mirror and I look as right
as right can be no one is as right as me
this the second which has they sort of
appeared as the same or a similar rhythm
that's why I mentioned it it's called
honey and jam what's your name Carol can
you read Carol how are you hey come come
help me okay okay I'm gonna point to
something when I point to it you read it
okay you ready
this is called honey and jam Jane and
Sue Jill too went to the store for honey
Jane complained voice pained sewages
lost their money
sadly Jill quite ill said that it wasn't
funny this honey less money less mess in
this moment of deepest distress this day
went tears and nameless fears seemed to
be finding but
way on the ground sue found there was
the missing money with her cries dark
skies suddenly changed to sunny to
Earling curls those girls ran in to buy
their honey this money full honey full
time this moment of laughter and rhyme
this day when Glee for heroines 3 seems
to be breaking oh no threw their hands
like sands trickled the jar of honey
down it crashed glass smashed wasting
their hopes and money they're at Lake
sad day gooey and wrecked and runny
honey gone money gone plight this moment
of horrible blight this time when doom
and poisonous gloom seem to be spreading
stop Jim explained voice strange
something that seemed quite funny jam on
bread well spread tastes even better
than honey jam they had so glad making
the world turned sunny this morning
begun with a boast this day much better
than most
when Jane and Sue and Jill - buttered
and jammed
I'm gonna read I'm gonna read a couple
of very short poems by XJ Kennedy who's
written three books about bad children
who come to bad ends the first is called
brats the sequel was called more brats
and the ultimate volume in this trilogy
was called drat those brats I think
they're very blocky in in their tone
although a little shorter so you'll hear
the sad stories of John of ours of
Randall and Eloise John while swimming
in the ocean rubbed sharks back with
suntan lotion
now this sharks have skin of bronze in
their bellies namely John's
on his motorbike bars stands roaring
past us look no hands soon with vacant
handlebars back the bike roars look no
bars at the fireworks show rash Randall
clinging to a roman candle took off
whoosh across the dark that lad said dad
will make his mark and finally camp fire
cooking Eloise
feta grizzly melted cheese to find out
did it like Welsh rarebit Eloise was
what the bear bit perhaps the deranged
shakes
what two and a half cycles of six adult
readers before the theme becomes
children torture murder and I don't know
how many of you shared my love for the
fables of ESOP when you were small
especially and adulteries and the lion
and I liked the update the one that not
the object actually the parallel ones
across the Muslim world now the stories
have Nasruddin Hodja the ESOP of Turkey
and Greece and Iran but there is there's
an American English version of the story
of the Fox and the Raven you remember
the Fox and the Raven
the dumb Raven that has the cheese and
the folks that teens the bird okay which
you know I think I can still summon from
memory if I if this fails I'll be down
to limericks but keep queue stop in mind
and and here it is a raven sat upon a
tree and not a word he spoke for his
beak contained a piece of Brie well
maybe it was wrote for will make it any
kind you please at all events it was a
cheese beneath the trees ombre just live
a hungry Fox sad
smiling extol the Raven watching him
spoken tones because II admire Athene
tombow blue marsh the which was simply
persiflage two things there are no doubt
you know to asia fox is used your
rooster that is bound to crow a crow
that's bound to roost and which so ever
he aspires he tells the most unblushing
lies sweet foul he said I understand
you're more than merely naughty I hear
you sing to beat the band and Adelina
Patti
pre-render with your golden tongue a bit
from Tamara this subtle speech was aimed
please the bird and it succeeded
thought no crow and all the trees could
sing as well as he did in flattery
completed asked he gave the jewel song
from fast but gravitations north course
as Isaac Newton showed it exerted on the
trees its force and else were soon
bestowed it in fact there isn't a need
to tell what happened when to earth it
fell I blush to add that when the bird
took in the situation he uttered one
emphatic word unfit for publication the
Fox was greatly startled but he only
sighed and answered the moral is a fox
is bound to be a shameless sinner and
also when the cheese comes around you
know it's after dinner but what is the
only note a few the Fox is after dinner
to this next poem I hesitated to bring
in and Jody said it was probably a good
idea to bring it in it's a kind of a
somber poem by gerard manley hopkins who
wrote it in 1881 September day and wrote
to his good friend Robby Bridges who I
believe was the poet laureate at the
time being yeah that he was not very
happy with it he said it didn't it
wasn't based on a real incident but it
has to do with mortality and all I think
children understand something about that
anyway it goes something like this
Margaret are you grieving over golden
Grove on leaving leaves like the things
of man you with your fresh thoughts care
for can you as the heart grows older
it'll come to such sights colder
by-and-by North's Paris I though worlds
of one would leave me a lie and yet you
will leap and know why now no matter
child the name sorrows Springs are the
same normal or mind expressed what heart
heard ghosts guessed it is the blight
that man was born for it is Margaret you
mourn for
I was actually going to read a poem from
additional power from a melon but I'm so
terrified of Christopher's contempt for
such maudlin sentimentality I think I'll
pass on that and move to the safe refuge
of TS Eliot - is that okay with you I
think you know there's music's feel I'm
mildly anti-semitic like you'll have no
walks 20th century so and this is
appropriate because the American in this
case yeah yeah this is appropriate I
think because it's Macavity the mystery
cat by TS Eliot and we had a cat have a
cat and the cat the cat threw most of
our kids growing up we now have a dog I
should hasten to add as well out of
treatment for the dog but he was only
when he only came to replace one of the
kids when she went to college first the
cat the cat actually he was there with
the kids and we like mysteries so it's
an appropriate phone Macavity the mr.
cat Macavity is a mystery cat he's
called the hidden paw for he's the
master criminal who can defy the law
he's the bafflement of Scotland Yard the
flying squads to spare for when they
reached the scene of the crime the
cavities not there a cavity Macavity
there's no one like Macavity he's broken
every human law he breaks the law of
gravity his powers of levitation would
make a faker stare and when you reach
the scene of crime the cavities not
there he may seek him in the basement
you may look up in the air but I tell
you once and once again the cavities not
there the cavities a ginger cat he's
very tall and thin you'd know him if you
saw him for his eyes are sunken in his
brows deeply lined with thought his head
i'li don't his coat is dusty from
neglects his whiskers are uncombed he
sways his head from side to side with
movements like a snake when you think
he's half-asleep
he's always wide-awake the cavity
Macavity there's no one like Macavity
for he's a fiend and feline shape a
monster of depravity you may meet him in
a by-street you may see him in the
square but when a crime is discovered
then the cavities not there he's
outwardly respectable they say cheats at
cards and his footprints are not found
in any file of Scotland Yard's and when
the larger saluted or the jewel-case is
rifled or when the milk is missing or at
other Peaks been stifled or the
greenhouse glass is broken and the
trellis passed repair I there's the
wonder of the thing the cavities not
there and when the Foreign Office finds
a treatise got astray or the Admiralty
loses some lose some plans and drawings
by the way there may be a scrap of paper
in the hall or on the stair but it's
useless to investigate the cavities not
there and when the loss has been
disclosed the Secret Service says it
must have been Macavity that he's a mile
away you'll be sure to find him resting
or a licking of his thumbs or engaged in
doing complicated long division sums a
cavity macavity there's no one like the
cavity there never was a cat
such deceitfulness and suavity he always
has an alibi and one or two to spare and
whatever time the deed took place but
cavity wasn't there and they say that
all the cats whose wicked deeds are
widely known I might mention MUNGO JERRY
I might mention brittle bone are nothing
more than agents for the cat who all the
time just controls their operations the
Napoleon of crime
Jodee and Dana's vivid gruesome
offerings suggest one answer to what it
is children want out of poetry and it is
an answer summarized perfectly by this
last poem I'll read by Ogden Nash which
happens to be a christum youths favorite
so Chris this one's for you
Don't Cry darling it's blood all right
is the title whenever poets want to give
you the idea that something is
particularly meek and mild they compared
it to a child thereby proving that
though poets with poetry may be right
they don't know the facts of life if of
compassion you desire either a tittle or
a jot don't try and get it from a top
hard-boiled sophisticated adults like me
and you may enjoy ourselves thoroughly
with Little Women and Winnie the Pooh
but innocent infants these titles from
their reading course eliminate as soon
as they discover that it was honey and
nuts and mashed potatoes instead of
human flesh that Winnie the Pooh and
little lemonade innocent infants have no
use for fables about rabbits or donkeys
or tortoises or porpoises what they want
is something with plenty of well
mutilated corpuses not on legends of how
the Rose came to be a rose instead of a
petunia is their fancy fed but on the
inside story of how somebody's bones got
ground up to make somebody else's Brad
they'll go to sleep listening to the
story of the little beggar maid who got
to be queen by being kind to the bees
and the birds but they're all eyes and
ears the minute they suspect a wolf or a
giant is going to tear some poor
woodcutter into quarters or thirds it
really doesn't take much to fill their
cup all they want for is somebody to be
eaten up therefore I say unto you all
you poets who are so crazy about me can
my little children and their angelic
heir if you are sincere and really want
to please them why just go out and get
yourselves devoured by a bear
hearing Tim reeds spring and fall to a
young child reminds me there is a
sadness in children's poetry I mean some
of the poems the children like there's a
reason that some of Edgar Allen Poe's
poetry for instance Annabel Lee and the
rest of it have a kind of resonance I
think trying to read your children only
bouncy happy poetry is a little like
feeding them Ritalin and I offer this to
Mary who's just written the book about
how we shouldn't be doing that it seems
to me of course you can go overboard
Kenneth Grahame who wrote The Wind in
the Willows once edited an anthology of
Victorian children's verse in which he
said that this that there was enough
Victorian children's verse about
funerals that one could make a nice
little anthology of funeral for the
education of children and that he
decided though he wasn't going to do
that but there is a harder-edged the
children's poetry can have this is not
the best of them this is a poem of mine
that strikes me as perhaps the most anti
school thing I've ever written it's
called my fall and it goes schools neat
take your seat that's what teachers said
some fools like rules
I replied instead hauled out parents
shout world turned gray and slow please
don't I won't and back to school I go
but the skies not fooled and the wind
unschooled whispers through the trees
that the hills have seats where the air
tastes sweet and long grass sways with
the breeze and the leaves need lots of
watching tumbling as they fall and from
the South the wild geese look back as if
to call come come come with us dwindling
with the fall fading as they call
schools fine stand in line teacher says
next day I do it's true listen and obey
new pens new friends timesing 6x4
new days new ways as teacher shuts the
door but the unpinned wind in the open
sky rights with whispered sound a
forgotten joyce and friendless toys that
played along the ground and the trees
are always waiting as light begins to
fall and high above the bright leaves
the wild geese still call come come come
with us dwindling with the fall fading
as they call you also read us a sort of
us a elegiac poem I mean I think having
dispatched so many children already on
this panel the least we can do is have
an elegy this is also by XJ Kennedy who
told me that he had wants a little girl
who had lived down the street died and
he'd never met her but he had seen her
in the front yard skipping rope little
elegy for a child who skipped rope
here lies resting out of breath out of
turns Elizabeth whose quick silver toes
not quite cleared the whirring edge of
night earth whose circles round us skims
till it catch the lightest winds shelter
now Elizabeth and for her sake trip up
death
there comes a time I think especially if
you're male and if you're English well
they'll they'll give you poetry in a
sense to build character
it'll be about history and it will be
about heroism and about fortitude George
Orwell makes the observation that some
of this poetry is very good bad but his
obvious very bad good poetry and the
test of the car to separate the two is
whether or not it has the Faculty of
recurring to the mind at crucial moments
Henry Newberg would be an example for
with the drakes drum Freitas in his
hammock and a thousand miles away
captain of the sleeping there below
slung between the roundshot in nombre de
Dios Bay but dreaming all the time of
play with her or um the sound of the
desert is sodden red this is his feet
island pas de red with the blood of a
square that broke and the gatlings
charmed the Colonel's dead the regiment
choten blind he would smoke the river of
death has burst its banks and England's
find honor a name but voice the
schoolboy right is the ranks play up
play up and play the game you either
find that pathetic or pathetic or
stirring that folks are going to taste
and the times but there's one poem that
absolutely exemplifies this ethos and
which for some reason never dies I think
for many good reasons is reborn in all
generations and it's Kipling's if which
I'll close on if I may if you can keep
your head when all about you are losing
theirs and blaming it on you if you can
trust yourself when all men doubt you
but make allowance for their doubting
too if you can wait and not be tired by
waiting or being lied about don't deal
in lies or being hated don't give way to
hating and yet don't look too good nor
talk too wise if you can dream and not
make dreams your master
if you can think and not make thoughts
your aim if you can meet with triumph
and disaster and treat these two
Impostors just the same if you can bear
to hear the truth you've spoken twisted
by knaves to make a trap for fools or
watch the things you gave your life to
broken and stoop and build them up with
worn-out tools if you can make one heap
of all your winnings and risk it on one
turn of pitch-and-toss and lose and
start again at your beginnings and never
breathe a word about your loss if you
can force your heart and nerve and sinew
to serve your turn long after they are
gone and so hold on well there is
nothing in you except the will that says
hold on hold on if you can talk with
crowds and keep your virtue or walk with
Kings nor lose the common touch if
neither foes nor loving friends can hurt
you and all men count with you but none
too much if you can fill the unforgiving
minute with sixty seconds worth of
distance run yours is the world and
everything that's in it and what is more
you'll be a man my son
now poetry is obviously that's just
something that adults do to read to
children but children sometimes can do
to read to each other or back to adults
how many people in this room have heard
of Maddy's Stepanek anybody any of the
kids Maddie was from just outside the
district in Maryland and had a unique
way of celebrating the beauty the joy
the enchantment he found in his life
even though he struggled with a very
difficult disease and Maddie passed from
us into that great mystery toward which
he had such profound hope this past year
I believe and he was 11 years old so I
can read a couple of poems that he wrote
if I may
I smell something
it smells like a noise like a turtle
noise yes that's what it is it's a
turtle noise and it's wonderful because
turtles live inside of seashells would
you like to live in a seashell they
would smell like a turtle noise but I
think it'd be wonderful
this one is called important things when
I grow up I think maybe I'll be a
snowman because when it snows that side
I'll already be cold and like it and
children will play with me and laugh and
sing and dance all around me
and those are important things to have
happen when you grow up
and lastly this one is called leaf for a
day today I think I'll be a tree or
perhaps a leaf on the branch of a tree I
will feel the gentle breeze and then I
will off my branch in my tree and float
in the wind I will go back and forth on
the breeze all the way down to the
ground and after I rest and say hello to
the grass and dirt and bugs I will call
to the wind come and take me to visit my
other leaf friends and on all the other
trees please and the gentle breeze will
come and pick me up so that I can jump
and dance with all of the other tree
stars and tree flowers that God gave the
world what a special idea to be today
I thought I might close actually like
Christopher with a edifying young boys
poem I I think this was my favorite poem
perhaps when I was in junior high school
or sometimes like that this is
Tennyson's charge of the Light Brigade
it's um Tennyson you have to have one
Kipling in one Tennyson and such a in
such a in such a reading I suppose I
think it's also relevant to today since
those of us would worry that secretary
Rumsfeld didn't send enough troops to
Iraq is it yeah I just want to make one
public policy reference here Chris
DeMuth sake you know but I'm sure we
will not meet the the American troops
there and the Iraqi friends will not
meet the same set and just the as the
British in Crimea so this is Tennyson's
charge of the Light Brigade half a
league half a league half a league
onward all in the valley of death rode
the six hundred forward the Light
Brigade charge for the guns he said into
the valley of death rode the six hundred
forward the Light Brigade was there a
man dismay'd
not though the soldiers knew somewhat
had blundered there is not to make reply
theirs not to reason why theirs but to
do and die into the valley of death rode
the six hundred cannon to the right of
them cannon to the left of them cannon
in front of them volleyed and thundered
stormed at was shot and shell boldly
they rode and well into the jaws of
death into the mouth of hell
rode the six hundred flashed all their
sabers bare flash as they turned in air
savoring the Gunners they're charging an
army while all the world wondered
plunged in the battery smoke right
through the line they broke Cossack and
russian wheeled from the saber stroke
shattered and thundered then they rode
back but not not the six hundred cannon
to right of them cannon to left of them
cannon behind them volleyed and
thundered stormed at was shot and shell
while horse and hero fell they that had
fought so well came through the jaws of
death back from the mouth of hell all
that
left of them left of 600 when can their
glory fade oh the wild charge they made
all the world wondered Honor the charge
they made honor the Light Brigade noble
600 well now that even Bill Kristol has
deserted me as an ally I finally
ascertained my real purpose on the panel
which is to relentlessly anchor the
lowbrow wing of this room you'll notice
they put it on the far right I would
like to read in defense of shel
silverstein once shel silverstein poem
this is for the kids in the room and
it's a perfect example of what Ogden
Nash was talking about so far as what
kids look for in poetry it's called
screamin Millie and it's been a big hit
in my house Millie McDevitt screamed
scream so loud it made her eyebrows
steam she screamed so loud her jaw bone
broke her tongue caught fire her
nostrils smoked her eyeballs boiled and
then popped out her ears flew north her
nose went south
her teeth flew out her voice was wrecked
her head went sailing off her neck over
the hillside crossed the stream into the
sky as it chased the scream and that's
what happened to Millie McDevitt at
least I hope all you screamers believe
it
well what do you want here to close you
want something bouncy or do you want
something bouncy there's a poet that I
like a lot named David McCoy who never
managed to write successful adult verse
really but as children's first there's
something about you can see this in the
children's worse that Kipling rights
that others of the poet's that we've
read including mill there's some kind of
metrical genius in certain children's
writers that doesn't translate well into
adult poetry and yet just has perfect
bounces this is these are a couple
little poems from David McCord
this one's called Isabel Jones in Kirov
Elly Isabel Jones in kuru Belle Lee
lived on butter and bread and tea and as
to this they would both agree
Isabel Kirov L Jones and Lea Isabel said
while prints have stones they are too
promising food for Joan's hirable said
well as for me tripe is a terrible thing
for Lea there's not a dish or fowl or
fish for which we wish said I and see
and that is why until we die we'll eat
no pie nor beg nor buy but butter and
bread and a trace of tea signed Isabel
kuru bell Jones and yes she also has
these short little chance for children
that I that strike me as perfect
although I had trouble selling them to
some of the children to whom I rent them
but y'all tried on this this one's
called the pickety fence and he's trying
to make the poem itself sound like the
noise you would make if you ran a stick
down a picket fence and it goes the
picket fence the picket fence give it a
lick it's a picket fence give it a lick
it's a cookie defense give it a look at
some look a defense give it a lick give
it a lick with a rickety stick Piketty
Piketty Piketty pick
and finally standed here this evening I
want to read one more chant from him
which is called every time I climb a
tree and it goes every time I climb a
tree every time I climb a tree every
time I climb a tree I scrape a leg or
skin and knee and every time I climb a
tree I find some answer dodge a bee and
get the ants all over me and every time
I climb a tree where have you been they
say to me but don't they know that I am
free every time I climb a tree I like it
best to spot a nest that has an egg or
maybe three and then I skim the other
leg it but every time I climb a tree I
see a lot of things to see swallows
rooftops and TV and all the fields and
farms to be every time I climb a tree
the climbing may be good for ants Adhan
isn't awfully good for pants but still
it's pretty good for me every time I
climb a tree you want to thank you all
for coming and thank all of our readers
here Dana Joya
Christopher Hitchens Tim Kelleher food
crystal and Mary ever staff thank you
all for coming and Michael Novak thank
you for having us
this panel was hosted by the American
Enterprise Institute on the web at AEI
dot-org in exit surveys the number one
issue on voters minds in the 2004
election was moral values neuroscientist
Sam Harris takes a critical